in the last video we learned a little
bit about what a chiral molecule or what
a chiral carbon or a chiral atom is what
I want to do in this video is go through
a bunch of examples and see if we can
identify if there are any chiral atoms
and to also see if we're dealing with a
chiral molecule so let's go look at our
examples here so here I have what is
this this is chloro cyclo pentene so the
first question is do we have any do we
have any chiral atoms and when we look
at our definition that we thought of
chiral atoms it all comes from this
notion of handedness and not being able
to be superimposable on your mirror
image but we said that they're usually
carbons bonded to four different groups
so let's see it do we have any carbons
here bonded to four different groups
well all the ch2 s they're bonded to
another ch2 and then two H's I could
draw it I could draw it like this H and
H so they're bonded to two of the same
groups so none of these none of these
ch2s
none of these CH 2 s are good candidates
for being a chiral Center or chiral
carbon they're both bonded to or all of
them are bonded to two hydrogen's and
then two other very similar-looking ch2
groups although you have you have to
look at the entire group that it's
bonded to but they're both they're all
definitely bonded to two hydrogen's so
it's not 4 different groups
if we look at this CH right here we
could separate it out like this we could
separate the h out like this and so it's
bonded to a hydrogen this carbon is
bonded to a chlorine and then it's
bonded to well it's not clear when you
look at it right from the get-go whether
this group is different than this group
but if you go around if you were to if
you were to kind of split if you were if
you were to split it halfway like this
or maybe another better way to think
about it is if you were to go around if
you were to go around this molecule in
that direction the counterclockwise
direction you would encounter a ch2
group and then you would encounter a ch2
group and then you would encounter third
then you would counter a fourth ch2
group then you'd come back to where you
were before so you would encounter 4 CH
2s and then you come back to where you
were before if you go in this direction
what happens you encounter 1 2 3 or CH 2
s and you come
back to where that you were before so
all of this kind of this bottom group
depending on how far you want to extend
it and this top group are really the
same group so this is not this is not
not not a chiral Center not a chiral not
a chiral Center or not a chiral carbon
it's not bonded to four different groups
and this is also not a chiral molecule
because it does not have a chiral Center
and to see that it's not a chiral
molecule let me see if I can backtrack
this back toward the way I was wrote it
right before so see that it's not a
chiral molecule there's a couple of ways
you could think about it
the easiest way or the way my brain
likes to think about is just to think
about its mirror image it's Miriam it
will look like this
it's so if that's the mirror you would
have a chlorine and then you have a CH
ch2 ch2 and you have a ch2 ch2 and then
you complete your your cyclopentane now
in this situation is there any way to
rotate this to get this over there well
if you just took this molecule right
here and you just rotated it 180 degrees
if you just rotated this 180 degrees
what would it look like if you just just
complete well maybe a little over yeah
about a about a well not quite 180
degrees but if you were to rotate it if
you were to rotate it so that the
chlorine goes about that far you would
get this exact molecule you would get
something it would look a little bit
different it would look like this let me
see if I can let me see if I can do it
justice it would look like it would look
like this you would have a ch2 so let me
let me do it up here where we have a
little bit more space so if I were to
rotate this if I were to rotate this
about that far I would get a CH you get
the chlorine and then you have a and
then you have your ch2 and then you have
another CH
ch2 ch2 and then you would have your ch2
up there if you were to rotate this all
the way around or actually this is about
this is exactly undred 80 degrees it
would look like this and the only
difference between this and this is just
how we drew this bond here I could have
easily instead of drawn that bond like
that I could draw it facing up like that
and these are the exact same molecule so
this molecule is also is also not chiral
now let's go to this one over here so I
have a so what what is this this is
bromo chloro fluoro methane just
practice our naming a little bit but
it's very clear that we are bonded to
four different groups all of the
different groups or the atoms in this
case that are bonded to this carbon are
different so this carbon is a chiral
center chiral center and it should also
be pretty clear that it is not it is
also a chiral molecule if you were
taking its mirror image and this is very
similar to the example we did in the
first video on chirality but it's mirror
image will look like this you have the
bromine on the right now the hydrogen is
still and back and then you have the
fluorine above it no matter how you try
to rotate this thing if you try to get
the bromine all the way over there all
the way to that position then the
hydrogen would be in this position and
the chlorine would be in that position
and no matter how you try to flip this
around or rotate it or shift it you will
never be able to superimpose this
molecule on that molecule right there so
that is a chiral Center and this is a
chiral molecule chiral molecule and
there's a word for these two versions
these two versions we're going to go to
the naming of them later on it's a
little bit more involved we'll have a
whole separate video on it but these two
versions of bromo chloro fluoro methane
they sometimes have different chemical
properties and these are called
enantiomers and then shimmers and
enantiomers are just are just the the
the the mirror images it each enantiomer
is a mirror image of each other but they
are stereo isomers so they are stereo
these are all just this is all just
terminology stereo isomers you're
familiar with the word isomer and isomer
just means that you have the same you
have the same atoms in your molecule but
then you have different types of isomers
you have constitutional isomers that say
okay you're different things are
connected to different things stereo
isomers are the same things are all
connected to the same things you have a
carbon connected to only a fluorine a
claw a chlorine connected to the carbon
a hydrogen connect to the carbon a
bromine connect to the carbon so all of
the same things are connected to the
same things but they're
three-dimensional configuration that's
where we're dealing with the stereo part
stereo chemistry is the study of
three-dimensional three-dimensional
chemistry as essentially understanding
the actual three-dimensional structure
of things so stereo isomers mean that we
have the same we have the same
constituents the same atoms they have
the same constituent they have the same
connections to each other bromine is
still combing is still connected to
carbon which is still connected to
hydrogen that's all true over here but
they're three-dimensional they're
three-dimensional orientation is still
different and in this case where they
are mirror images of each other we call
them enantiomers enantiomers and I
should probably make one clarification
in the last few videos I've been a
little bit you know sometimes I'll say
configuration and sometimes I'll use the
word conformation so sometimes I'll use
the word configuration and sometimes I
use the word conformation and I actually
should be a little bit more or I should
have been a little bit more exact about
these when you're talking about a
configuration you're actually about
talking about a different structure to
go from one configuration to another
configuration you would actually have to
break bonds and kind of reassemble them
so these are different configurations
because in order for them to be able to
be the same thing you would have to swap
maybe the bromine and the hydrogen in
there where they are relative to the
carbon so these are different
configurations confirmations are really
just different shapes or different
orientations of the same molecule so
when we talked about cyclohexane
being in a boat so this is cyclohexane
being in a boat conformation or this is
the cyclohexane being in a chair
conformation it's the exact same
molecule with the exact same connections
we didn't detach any bonds or reattach
any bonds they just flipped around a
little bit so these are two different
confirmations
these are two different configurations
to go from one configuration to another
you have to rearrange bonds now let's
look at this molecule over here can we
identify any stereo centers or chiral
carbons or chiral atoms and you have
this carbon right here see this carbon
right here it's bonded to a chlorine a
hydrogen or bromine and then another
carbon so this is bonded to four
different things so this is this is a a
chiral carbon and sometimes they put
little asterisks there but if we look at
this carbon right here you can well it's
bonded to a fluorine another carbon but
it's bonded to two different it's bonded
to two hydrogen's so it's not chiral it
has two of the same things that it's
bonded to you can even see a little axis
of symmetry through it if you look at
that you can kind of flip it over and
it's going to be the same thing but this
one right here that is a chiral Center
that is a chiral Center or chiral carbon
or chiral atom or asymmetric carbon
you'll see it used in different ways and
because this molecule has got that
chiral Center you'll see that if you
were to take its mirror image it would
be an enantiomer
this is not superimposable on its mirror
image we could even we could even try to
draw it and just show you don't always
have to do the mirror image on the right
side we could draw the mirror image on
the left side so if we want to draw its
mirror image it would look like this you
would have a fluorine carbon carbon
chlorine you have your two hydrogen's
and then you would have a hydrogen here
and then you would have your bromine
here no matter what you try to do if you
try to flip this around or whatever you
will never be able to superimpose this
on top of this so these are enantiomers
these are both Stier isomers really of
relative to each other and either of
these regardless of which one you pick
are chiral molecules so these are chiral
chiral molecules I'm over the time that
I normally want to go in the video so in
the next video I'll do even more
examples of this